لقد كانت واحدة من الأماكن المفضلة لدينا
خلال بطولة كأس العالم هذه ،
لقد شعرت حقًا وكأنها قرية عالمية
مع مشجعين من جميع الفرق الـ 32 والعديد
من البلدان الأخرى الذين يجتمعون هنا
للاستمتاع بصحبة بعضهم البعض في كثير من الأحيان
في وقت متأخر من الليل.
المشجعين هنا الليلة مع بقاء ثلاثة أيام
حتى النهائي ربما يكون
الهدوء قبل العاصفة ، لكن لا يزال
هناك جو رائع وطاقة رائعة
وجو جيد حقًا ونأمل أن
نجد بعض مشجعي الأرجنتين وفرنسا
لنرى ما يفكرون فيه بشأن الحدث الكبير.
game
[Music]
شكرًا لك ،
فعندما سافرنا إلى هنا قبل أربعة
أسابيع بالطبع كنا نتطلع بشدة
إلى البطولة وكنت
أتساءل عما إذا كنت سأفقد
الكحول فرصة تناول بيرة بين
الحين والآخر  الحقيقة هي
أنني لم أفعل ذلك حقًا ، لذا سأقدم لك
نائبنا الجديد الذي نحب هذه غالبًا
في وقت متأخر جدًا من الليل فهي
لذيذة تمامًا
[موسيقى]
حسنًا
أشعر أن الأرجنتين كانت على الطريق
مائة بالمائة
كل شيء الفريق جيد حقًا
إنه مثله معًا أعتقد
أنه أفضل شيء لدينا الآن 78 86 وأنا
متأكد من أن ميسي سيفوز إن شاء الله وأنا
أدعم ميسي من كل قلبي وأنا
أدعم الأرجنتين وميشيل دعنا
سأفوز ، حسنًا ، سيكون الأمر صعبًا ولكنه
سيكون جيدًا وستفوز الأرجنتين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] حار جدًا ،
لذلك خلال فترة وجودنا هنا في قطر ،
استمتعنا حقًا
بالطعام الرائع جدًا من جميع أنحاء
المنطقة التي كان لدينا فيها إيرانيًا ، كان
لدينا تركي ، كان لدينا كويتيون لدينا
لبنانيون معجبون جدًا بالطعام اللبناني
وليس الفرنسي ولا الطعام الفرنسي ، ولست
متأكدًا من وجود أي مشجعين فرنسيين هنا
الليلة ، لذلك دعونا نستمر في البحث إيه.
حسنًا ، أنا مسرور جدًا لأننا وجدنا بعض
المشجعين الفرنسيين هنا لأنه لا يوجد الكثير
منكم في قطر في الوقت الحالي ، نعم ، ما
هو شعورك تجاه يوم الأحد ،
نحن سعداء للذهاب إلى النهائيات
هناك ، لذا أه أتمنى أن  المدرب سيكون
جيدا اللاعب سوف يضيع قليلا
سيكون الأمر قريبًا من
الأرجنتين الأخرى لأن فريقًا جيدًا لديه
لاعبان اثنان جيدان ، أحدهما مشهور
أعتقد أن الاسم مثل ميسي
، أعتقد أن شيئًا من هذا القبيل ، لذا
ربما سنفوز كما تعلمون أننا
مدربنا هو  جيد ، إنه ذكي ،
محظوظ ، لذا فإننا نضع إصبعك على
أه ، سيكون على ما يرام ، هل تشعر
بالثقة ،
نعم أنت تعلم أننا كما قلت نحن
لاعب جيد جدًا ، أثق في فريقي ، وأنا
أثق في المدرب ، لذلك نحن واثقون ولكن
لا يمكننا ذلك.  لنفترض أننا واثقون تمامًا من 100
لأنها لا تزال الأرجنتين ، لذلك نحن
سعداء جدًا باللعب ضد
الأرجنتين ، ستكون مباراة جيدة
كرة قدم رائعة ، لكن نعم لا يمكننا أن نقول 100
ثقة ، لذا نجحت الأرجنتين وفرنسا
في شق طريقهما إلى
العالم.  نهائي الكأس ، وإذا خسرت
في البدلة لأنني فعلت
ذلك في وقت سابق من هذا المساء ، فهذه هي
نجمك الشمالي ، إنها الإبهام الذهبي الذي تم
تصميمه لإحياء ذكرى فوز قطر غير المتوقع
في كأس آسيا 2019 وهي
طريقة مناسبة  تنتهي هنا
لأنه بالطبع ستكون
عطلة نهاية أسبوع ذهبية للغاية ، كأس العالم على
المحك ، الحذاء الذهبي على المحك وأي
شخص يفوز يوم الأحد قد يجد
هناك تمثال ليونيل ميسي أو
يقتل mbappe بالذهب هنا يومًا ما في
المستقبل دون ريدل سي إن إن قطر